foreign
my husband and I have identical twin
girls we decided to split them up into
separate classrooms in kindergarten my
one daughter has like taken off and is
thriving my other has said zero word
like we've read all the books we've
tried all the things that we can think
of and we're out of tools but I would
bring this to you we've talked to the
professionals we're going to the podcast
[Music]
what up what up
what up John with the Dr John deloney
show man so good to be with you hope
you're doing well
talking about your mental health and
relationships whatever else is going on
in your world there's a lot going on for
crying out loud if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask
um all right I don't know if you can
pick this up if you're listening to this
just imagine
um I don't know if we can pick it up on
the cameras but I had I I just bought a
new bow I want to learn how to use a bow
and arrow and because it's the 16th
century and so me and my son got him and
man I didn't hold on to it so I don't
know if you can catch and see this but I
did it blew my arm up I uh pulled it
back and I let it man and my little girl
was sitting there looking at me it
swelled up through like a softball
inside of my on my phone on my forearm
and basically it was like uh
like snapping somebody snapping with a
rubber band at 70 miles an hour and my
daughter was sitting there and it
happened and I put it I saw it just
swell up real fast and I put it behind
my back and I looked at my daughter and
said
I need you to go get mommy real fast and
she said why dad why well let's talk
about dragons or whatever she want to
talk about and I said this is a 9-1-1
I need you to go get Mommy because daddy
hurt himself pretty bad and she looked
at me and then sprinted off and so this
is my reminder
have the conversations about
um this is a serious thing or not a
serious thing so another example is
sometimes in a grocery store or in a
restaurant somebody comes in and you
know this is about to be a not a good
situation so my house we have I just
preface it with 9-1-1
so I'll say hey child hey Hank hey
Josephine this is a 9-1-1 we have to go
and they know that when I say that
they're not going to ask any questions
they're not gonna like why what's good
they're going to pick up their stuff and
we're going to walk out the door I will
explain everything when we get to
wherever it is we need to go get in the
car where we're going or if I get hurt
somewhere I sometimes I don't have time
to or the mental capacity to uh explain
everything I need to go get your mom
because at that time I thought I'd shot
the arrow through my arm I don't know
how it hurts so I thought I'd shot
myself with an arrow which I don't even
know how you do that but if there's a
human being I can figure it out this guy
can yes um but I thought I'd done it so
I just had to go get Mom anyway have
that conversation with your kids it
doesn't have to be 9-1-1 it can be
something else it can be this is a a
green conversation you need to go get
that right now and they just need to
know hey we're not gonna ask questions
and even have this with your spouse
right
um I tend to be all over the place and
so I can tell my wife hey this is a 911
call I need you to come get me right now
and she would know cool I'll be right
there I'm not gonna ask any questions
I'm on the way
um obviously you should do that with my
staff like when when I worked with teams
I would set that up with my teams so if
I recall you and say
this is a 9-1-1 call I need everybody
out of that building
they would just say you got it and we
would have that conversation later
um instead of like I don't have time to
have the conversation with you right now
so just setting those those
um those conversations up with your
family for and they don't have to be I
know where
um lots of conversations about active
Shooters and all that stuff going on
that's a little part of it and we'll
have another episode about that later on
but
um it's more about just life like life
happens your dumb dad accidentally snaps
himself in the arm with a bow and arrow
and you know just like on a Sunday
afternoon and uh you need to go get you
need to go get some help so or fall off
a ladder or trip or whatever thing is so
have that conversation with your kids
have a conversation with your spouse and
even a couple of friends like I'm gonna
text you 9-1-1 and you come get me right
now got it I'm on it oh no questions uh
or come up with your own thing here so
that's my little uh what do you call it
PSA my public service announcement of
the day and let's go out to Hannah in
Albany what's up Hannah
hi not much how are you I'm good how are
you talking to you
what's up all right so my question is
how do I help my daughter overcome her
fear of talking in school and manage
anxiety so that she can function better
in school and not miss out on things so
um tell me about her talking she's not
talking
correct so um my daughter and I or my
husband and I have identical twin girls
you're going to be six soon um they did
two years of preschool and they've
always been like really introverted and
had um like really quiet temperaments
and then preschool were really
codependent and so we decided to split
them up into separate classrooms in
kindergarten and um my one daughter has
like taken off and is thriving my other
has said zero words and not the teachers
or other students
um the school counselor was concerned
and us too and so they started like a
small social group with her and then we
took us a while to find somebody but we
got her into a counselor in March
um and they say that she has anxiety and
that once we work through that then the
talking will come
um academically she's like perfectly
normal like the teacher has taught her
enough sign language to be like
functional in school and then also will
send home assessments and we send back
recordings and stuff so there's no like
academic or developmental delays
um and then her anxiety is also showing
up in other areas where like to the
point where she won't go to play dates
or even go to the park if there's too
many people there so we're just like
we've read all the books we've tried all
the things that we can think of and
we're out of tools and thought I would
bring this to you
we've talked to the professionals we're
going to the podcast well
um yeah so a couple things here so it
sounds like selective mutism have you
heard that phrase
I have yeah okay has anyone diagnosed
your kid with that no they haven't okay
I'm not gonna do that because I'm I
haven't seen your kid and I wouldn't
even be qualified to do that so
um selective mutism is a form of intense
anxiety so
when you are when your kid is just with
you guys at home she she little just
talking talking talk oh yeah yeah okay
yeah totally okay
I I really hate people who do what I'm
about to do which is to say that really
is what that sounds like who diagnosed
who put a diagnostic on the table
without any business doing so okay but
I'm doing that right now because I want
to equip you with those terms okay yeah
um
so a three-prong approach that I always
tie to anxiety when I'm trying to solve
an adult anxiety kid anxiety is based on
three pillars okay one is connection
or disconnection one is safety and one
is autonomy meaning I have some sort of
control in what happens next
and it surprises me zero that you've got
identical twins who are already a little
anxious already a little bit on the
introverted side quiet side if you will
and we split them up and then one of
them just has a it's a fear response
right it's their brain saying not safe
not safe not safe and what happens is we
look at it at the result of the not safe
not safe alarm and we come up with oh
you should talk more or you should chill
out or you should quit yelling whatever
the anxiety response happens to be and
in this case it is
um
it's she just doesn't talk
um
how's it tell me what how it's how it's
affecting you guys
um I think
I think it's hard for us as parents
because we don't like our goal isn't for
her to be this outgoing talkative kid
but we just want her to be able to like
like learn more in school like right now
it's fine because it's just kindergarten
and like we can help her with things
that she's not like because she can't
ask questions
um in school or she won't and um I think
also like it's hard for us when we take
when we go places and people are like oh
what's your name how old are you and
they just and she just stares them down
and doesn't give them anything and I'm
like I don't want to I don't like like
labeling her like oh you know that's
fine she's just shy and just like hey
like raise your hand if your name is
this this is your name or like can you
show them with your fingers how old you
are and like try to like give them a way
to or her a way to like answer without
having to talk without like
it's hard as a parent because I feel
like bad that she is so
like so anxious and okay so let's let's
do this I want you to begin to think of
somebody coming up to your daughter and
saying hi what's your name
I want you to imagine that she just saw
a bear
because that's what's happening in her
little brain okay and so what we
wouldn't want to do if you and I happen
to be walking on the sidewalk and we saw
a bear is to figure out a way to make us
get closer to that Bear right right so
there's gonna be a it's a it's a very
fine balance that you're gonna walk here
number one I really want you to find a
psychologist who's trained in selective
mutism not to diss my counselor brothers
and sisters that's my training is
counseling
um but I would get with a good
psychologist that can because this is a
very healable challenge okay it's a I
don't say solvable
um I have a hundred percent
um belief that your daughter can heal
from this okay and begin to come up with
some techniques it's learning how to
manage the anxiety and once you manage
the Upstream stuff the Alarm Systems
begin to back down Okay so
when your daughter see so we're gonna
walk a balance here between not putting
her in positions
to where her body feels like she's about
to get eaten
and we're going to create slowly it's
the word I use is probably not
technically correct it's it's slow
exposure therapy okay and we're gonna
slowly do I've heard of play therapists
using puppets I've heard him using toys
animals that talk um drawings one way
you can do this is to uh read a book
and just have her point to like a
children's book with pictures have her
point to who's who's talking Bob says
and then all she does is point this is
just y'all two at home okay and maybe in
public she can we're gonna teach her she
can talk to you in a whisper
what's your name you see what I'm saying
we're gonna slowly lean into this this
thing right
um and then here's the the balance I'm
not gonna put her in positions to where
she feels like she's at War and I'm
going to put her in situations where
speaking will get her something that she
desires
meaning we're going to go to a
restaurant this isn't something you're
going to do today this is something a
few weeks from now for you all have been
intentionally letting her know hey we're
going to begin to practice not speaking
we're going to begin to practice feeling
safe so when you don't feel safe I want
you to squeeze mommy's finger
and that's when we'll know that you're
going to whisper to me but you've got to
let us know via squeezing your finger
and then today we're gonna go get ice
cream
and the person's gonna ask you what your
flavor is and if you don't choose to
have ice cream that is okay
you don't have to say anything
but if you choose to have ice cream you
can whisper your name
and so we're not going to punish her in
a public setting when somebody some
well-meaning person says hey what's your
name honey you can say
um she's very very shy or she doesn't
always communicate with strangers uh you
can come up with some sort of mom
conversation okay because her body just
saw a bear and we're going to work on
that with the psychologist slowly but
surely
um teaching her how to have
conversations the other side of it is
we're going to put have some situations
that say hey
um
do you want to order your your Sprite
your special drink at the restaurant if
you don't that's okay if you choose
water that is okay
and what we're going to do is we're
going to teach her that speaking is not
evil in fact she can get what she needs
if she will learn to use that voice does
that make sense and there's going to be
big time tears on the back of that
expect that because she's gonna not say
have ice cream and her sister will be
like I want chocolate chip and you know
whatever and we're gonna do both
and we go outside she's gonna be crying
be upset and you're gonna say but you
chose not to and that's okay because you
didn't feel safe and that's okay but
when you feel safe then you can choose
to have that conversation right so we're
teaching that that anxiousness is a
context not an excuse it will also
provide some a little bit of gas in the
engine to practice when she's with the
psychologist or with counselor schools
are notoriously underprepared for this
because it's kind of outside the box and
schools are designed to deal with loud
problem kids not with the Quiet kids
making Straight A's does that mean you
know what I mean so there's just not a
lot of focus on it
um something you can practice at a
restaurant when they bring your food I
want you to whisper thank you thank you
right I want you want you to practice it
we're gonna practice these little things
practice little things and you have to
be careful not rushing to her age when
we're trying to get the things that she
wants right is that cool yeah yeah I
know it's hard and it's hard here's the
big thing
um I'm gonna leave the rest of dealing
with her to the adults
I'm gonna can I talk to you for a second
and I'm gonna say things and I don't
want you please promise me you won't go
straight to Mom internalization do you
promise right
you're about to I know you are please
don't you promise
I promise triple promise we're a triple
promise okay all right
okay
um
when our kids don't talk or they don't
show up in public sometimes they don't
talk they scream they kick they whatever
we wear that
does that make sense yeah no I and I do
that yeah so we wear it as though we're
failing them or that their kids are
somehow broken and here's how that Loop
begins
then we get we begin to
anticipate negatively social situations
which raises the temperature of our
bodies of our car on the way to go
somewhere as we're walking into a room
how tightly we're holding somebody's
hand or hey and we're gonna We Begin to
pregame and often pre-gaming is
um rehearsing the negative thing that's
about to happen as though we can out
rehearse it right and so we do these and
so what we do is we end up creating an
extra chaotic environment for an anxious
kid to enter into
see what I'm saying yeah that makes
sense so what I try not to do but I
think I know I know crying because that
so and
I can only imagine do you have other
kids besides these two no okay
apparently I have to imagine that having
two twins
blows up everything that you and your
husband knew is that right maybe not
yeah okay no for sure yeah is there have
y'all had the relationship conversation
of okay we're six years in everything's
different now
maybe not like that direct but
like what
conversation
um
two things one the number one thing when
somebody calls and says hey how do I get
my kid to be less anxious my number one
answer is always fix your marriage work
on your marriage
probably 85 to 95 of the time people
will either start crying or they drop
their head or they drop their shoulders
five percent of the time they're like no
my marriage is actually pretty great and
now that's great data for me
yeah I'd say or we're not five percent
okay things are awesome that's perfect
okay so what I want to do is where are
some ways that we can with our kids
create moments for connection
that are safe that give them some
autonomy
right so all autonomy means is I've got
some control and so at home we're going
to work on those things and then we're
going to start slowly inching inching
inching out into the public space
and my daughter gets to chew or your
daughter gets to choose oh you don't
want ice cream that's okay you don't
want to go to the park
since you didn't choose that here's what
this is going to look like right and I'm
just you just get to make those gentle
choices and it's okay and I'm not mad
I'm not frustrated and you as Mom are
going to be like I'm it's not a
scorecard on your end it's just her
sweet little brain responding as though
there's a bear out there
and I'm not going to over uh indulge and
I'm not gonna over you just gotta say
hello right I'm gonna I'm gonna try to
ride that balance and if you mess up
what you will just apologize and say I
didn't get that right this time uh we'll
try to get right next time and the best
you can don't compare to your sister
because I know that's hard see how Susie
gets ice cream because she asked for it
that makes it you know what I mean uh
we're just creating that world I am a
hundred percent confident sitting down
with a therapist who will practice with
the puppets practice with the reading
practice with these little tiny steps
and then at school
I'm gonna have her sit by a friend that
she can whisper to and speak to and that
that was some guided expertise will
slowly open up and I I don't have any
concerns about moving forward if y'all
get the help she needs that helps
expensive and it's annoying and it does
not usually take a whole bunch of
sessions okay okay
cool
um and hopefully you can find that that
connection there in your community and I
know that's hard and good for you guys
for having a great marriage here's the
the conversation I have in your marriage
go out and have a half day and say okay
we've had this challenge this year twins
are six a couple of those years we're in
the middle of a pandemic how are we
doing and then what do we want our
marriage to look like moving forward
what world do we want to have now we've
had two kids show up and blow it up in
the best ways and in the worst ways
um how do we want things move to look
moving forward and we're going to begin
to wrap our heads around building that
world and when you do that and you get
back on the same page and you are
connected in your goals you're connected
in what your look what you're aiming for
financially and emotionally and
spiritually and sexually all those
things together on the same page it
often provides a context for your kids
to go drop the shoulders there
um
so that's my thoughts there man she's
lucky to have you Hannah awesome awesome
awesome I've just got high hopes for you
guys um getting in there and getting the
um care that you need okay thank you so
much for call we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy we don't do
it and we don't even realize they
wouldn't even think about it you are
worth it this month better help online
therapy wants to remind you that you are
important that you are worth being well
and therapy is a super important way you
can show up for yourself better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
even live chat sessions with your
therapist you don't even have to see
anyone on a camera if you don't want to
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today Dr
John deloney show listeners get 10 off
their first month so decide to invest in
yourself you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com deloney to get 10 off
that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right what's up let's go to Brendan
in Sioux City
what is up Brendan
not a whole lot how you doing John we're
partying man what are you up to
oh just sitting at work that doesn't
sound fun at all you should quit I'm
just kidding don't quit more problems
yes don't quit your job what's up man no
all right so my my main question is how
do you have difficult conversations with
someone you don't necessarily have a lot
of buy-in with and they don't see a
problem
so
so back out I'm talking about one of my
co-workers okay and what's the what
are you in a supervisory relationship
with him or a or no they are we are
equals in our lab
we are equals just as an FYI
um you're equal as a human being with
all the people you work with uh well
this is true somebody may have a statue
they can fire you but
um so you're on the same level as they
are professionally
um what do you want to talk to them
about
well
they seem to have a lot of things going
on in their life but the the most
obvious one is myself my boss and
another co-worker we suspect that
they're a hoarder
um we don't have any concrete evidence
of their house but they've mentioned a
lot of things that kind of paint a
picture of that
um okay you know multiple storage units
of things and you know complaints from
previous landlords about clutter and
cleanliness and that sort of thing
well we do have evidence of is their
vehicle
um this employee Works second shift so
we don't they work in the afternoons and
evenings we just have a couple hours of
over you know overlap and they Park you
know right front center of the of the
building and um it's a big extended cab
truck with a topper and when I say it's
a one-seater like you couldn't fit
another human being in this vehicle okay
just
just floor to ceiling full of food and
stuff and you know it's getting to be
summer and it's getting kind of gnarly
yeah
so this is a great question for millions
of people we only have like 11 listeners
so Millions won't hear it just
um so this is a great question and I'm
going to answer it pretty directly is
that cool
sure okay
my answer to you is don't
okay don't play sideline armchair
therapist with people that you work with
um what I want folks to do is to focus
on behavior that impacts work
and here's what I mean and number two
focus on relationship so the first thing
is if you're a supervisor or you're got
colleagues that
um have the same job as you right y'all
on the same level there
um and somebody's late they're not
showing up they are stealing they like
you address the behavior of what's going
on
oftentimes people think oh Susie sounds
depressed or she's been really anxious
and all of a sudden you've got a group
of people trying to play armchair
psychiatrist and how do we talk to them
what do we need them to do that and that
turns into a disaster because either
they have true Diagnostics that they're
working with a professional and there's
some Ada violations right you're getting
into some disability conversations that
the workplace often doesn't need to get
into unless there's accommodations or
man there's we're judging part of a
situation and we don't know the whole
thing so if somebody's showing up to
work they're getting their job done they
are disheveled at times which I may or
may not be somebody put on the internet
the other day that uh man delony's
looking pretty rough
I mean and then I looked at myself and I
was like that's probably Fair looking
pretty rough
um but I want you to focus on that
behavior okay if they drive a car and
it's my car in the parking lot here is
ridiculous because it's not a great car
it's a piece of junk it's but it gets me
too it's not a piece of junk I don't
want to just diss it like that it gets
me ready to go
um and my friend said hey I don't want
to ride in there because it looks like
you live there right so I cleaned it out
because that was embarrassing to me but
what they didn't say was hey we he we
think you're a hoarder we think you have
problems okay so that's number one
number two
wait to be invited in Via relationship
and so this is where you say hey we're
all going out to get nachos or this is
an overlapping shift right so hey come
eat dinner with us come talk to us come
whatever and then we're going to focus
on the thing so if someone brings up
like yeah man I can't fit another thing
in my car you can say yeah I noticed
that what are you doing
and invite be invited into in more
information somebody hoarding is
notoriously
um hard right
but they may say yeah man I've been
struggling this forever and they're not
inviting you in not inviting you into a
solution they're inviting you into their
heart right and I know it sounds cheesy
the way I just said that but they're
inviting you into that relationship
um if they come to you and say hey you
and I've been I trust you I need some
help man like would you be willing to
help me and I actually had a colleague
do that and I went over to their house
and we spent several days
cleaning stuff out filled up dumpster
after dumpster after dumpster after
dumpster and it was earned over years of
became a it means it was a very close
friend someone I trusted highly somebody
trusted me and then it was an invitation
and there was just this glitch in The
Matrix where they said I'm ready to just
get rid of all this stuff and man came
over and we got rid of a lot of stuff
and so but that was you see what I'm
saying that was years and years of just
like they didn't invite me into that
conversation so I didn't try to solve
that I wasn't about solving that problem
it's gonna be a good friend see what I'm
saying right
um and so that's what I do man I focus
on the connectivity and if there's a way
y'all can get together outside of the
office you want to hang out cool
um you wanna have dinner if your shifts
overlap cool
um but other than that man I would let
home stuff be home stuff until you hear
about it the only time I get involved
is if there's some some inkling about
suicidal ideation
if someone's going to take their life if
somebody's saying I'm highly depressed
and I don't know what's next then I'm
going to get involved um then I'm going
to call it the calvary and all that but
when it comes to stuff like this it's
hard and it's challenging but I haven't
gotten invited in so I'm just going to
be your friend and love you at the
office is that fair
yes sir is that possible to do that in
your situation
um I I think so okay
um yeah I can definitely try that I mean
we've all been kind of arm sharing at
the three of us but uh we haven't had
much success yeah what I find we're
really hoping to it turns into the point
where she invites us it it it often
turns it so often
hoarding is a outgrowth of some pretty
significant trauma
and so man sometimes you pull back a
scab on something that people are not
equipped to handle okay so I'd be
careful about that number two often
little groups of two and three and four
armchairing you know trying to figure
something that can just turn into a real
gossipy mess
right and so I would love to have
someone like you with leadership
capacity with their with their
colleagues when she comes up again to be
like ah hey hey let's let's don't talk
about that
um let's invite her over to have with he
with us or I don't let's let's um she's
she's rocking and roll and doing her
thing and I I don't want to keep harping
on it
um and then let's do what we can do
includer uh into conversations and I
think that would be a gift to her a big
gift to you all and she's gonna bring
stuff to that relationship too
um but yeah stopped a little gossipy hey
what do you think about hey let's don't
do that let's let's have a different
workplace than that man there's enough
people beating up on each other and by
the way she knows
she knows she knows she can barely get
in her car
she knows that
um that her house or her storage units
are overflowing she knows she knows all
that stuff that she only has she only
wears the same few outfits because it's
the only thing she has access to it's
hard to get into the bathroom and shower
if she can't she knows all that stuff
um
the way through that is through
connection not through hey look at you
look at you which tends to drive that
spiral even Tighter and faster so thank
you so much for the call Brandon it's a
great call and to you guys listening
um this isn't just about hoarding this
is about all like I think she's got I
think she's got anxiety disorder I'm
pretty sure she got borderline
personality disorder dude that guy for
sure has bipolar for sure has bipolar I
know it you know what I think she's got
let's don't do that let's leave
Diagnostics to the diagnostic to the
professionals let me see it that way to
the psychiatrist to the therapist the
counselors and psychologist and let's
focus on connecting with people being
friends they'll have hard Behavior
conversations when we need to
but let's focus on being humans and
connected we'll be right back
there are lots of things that make me
nuts but one thing makes me more nuts
than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too I love living in a
new home but I gotta be honest
I'm no good at buying one and that's why
I'm so thankful for people like my
friends at Churchill Mortgage Churchill
is a Ramsay trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why because
they're committed to doing what's right
for you and that means walking you
through paperwork that's way over your
head that means making sure you get the
right mortgage that you can pay off as
soon as possible and then I'll try to
upsell you a bunch of nonsense that's
going to hurt you down the road and most
importantly when you're making this big
life change you can actually
oh breathe because you got an expert and
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change save yourself the headache
and call Churchill Mortgage today at
Triple Eight loan 200. trust me that's
Triple Eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement nmls ID
1591 in mlsconsumeraccess.org Equal
Housing lender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite
100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back and we have a
brand new segment that we're gonna try
out called lightning round so here's the
deal we get calls from all over the
planet and email social media requests
all this and Kelly and Jen they've been
compiling these questions and they turn
into shows and what we don't want to do
is ask answer the same question over and
over and over so they just they get the
pile gets bigger and bigger and bigger
and
Kelly wants to know these things for her
personal life too sometimes and so she
puts them on there as well and so we've
got this new segment called lightning
round here's how it's going to work
Kelly is going to read from a compiled
list of questions that you all sent in
or that she's secretly planted there and
I got one minute to answer them because
rumor has it I talk too much we also
have an entire Studio full of people and
by entire Studio full people I mean
there's one dude out there he's
incredible you just thumbs down me man
if I miss it okay so part of this is
gonna be me on the spot partis is going
to be having to say I don't know off top
of my head or I have an expert that I
would like to call I might even say
their name like if I got this question I
would call this expert uh some of it
might be me just winging it from the hip
and some of it might be right in my
wheelhouse I don't know exactly right
the answer but we're gonna go for it so
welcome everybody to the introductory
section segment called lightning round
here we go we ready to party let's do it
and by the way can we just say
Sarah in the in the graphics team look
how cool this is man it's amazing all
right let's do this
all right first question how do you know
when to stop fighting for your marriage
oh okay I think you should stop fighting
for your marriage when
both of you have give or one or both of
you have given up okay so if what if
you're fighting and the person you're
fighting with or what fighting for on
behalf of is not interested in
participating they have stopped being a
part of the marriage then I'm gonna lay
the weapons down we're done number two
if I'm fighting somebody I'm not
fighting you we're fighting for this
thing I'm not fighting you and I would
say the third thing how do I know if
I've decided that I'm out
if I've decided I'm out and we often
think well I'll know when I'm out when I
decide to quit fighting no that's not
true if you're in the marriage if you
want this thing to work if you want to
be a part of this thing then you're
going to keep going the moment you say I
can't do this anymore and I'm beginning
to step out that's when it's over is
that a good answer I don't know what do
you think works for me all right all
right let's go
do you agree with the cry it out method
for babies no I do not I don't
um uh
no I don't
um and I know I get a lot of flack for
that on the internet so I don't care
um the best way to to for True Behavior
change is through connection not through
um disassociation not through fracturing
a relationship and so when a baby cries
it's a primal Instinct it is a response
hardwired into a child that says I need
to be reconnected that is not a thing
when a child quits crying that means
they've exhausted their bodies right
um so not a their body's ability to say
I need help I need help and then they
get quiet and quiet isn't them learning
how to be still with themselves quiet is
their body going into the free it's
fighter fighter free it's it's their
bodies starting to shut down okay
um so no I'm not a fan of cried out all
right next question how do you boost sex
drive
foreign
number one it starts with good tunes
right
um how do you boost sex drive uh well
I'd say number one sex drive isn't a
thing um sex drive isn't isn't real
um sex is as Emily nagoski suggests is a
series of um gas pedals and brakes and
so if you want to increase sexual
encounters in your home you want to
increase Intimacy in your home you're
going to look at the entire context so
for some people sex starts with the
amount of dishes in the sink and how
much we've talked this week and
sometimes sex is what you're wearing or
what you're not wearing or coming out of
the shower with a towel on your head
that's a signal that we're done for the
night or coming out of the shower right
so it's all contextual so if you want to
boost that overall with in in your home
you're going to sit down and have a
conversation about
how do we turn your ons on and how do we
turn your offs off all right next one
next question
what are your thoughts about online
dating
I think online dating is a great way to
transmit information with one another
it's a great way to find people in your
area that you wouldn't otherwise find
because people don't just go to roller
rinks anymore and they don't go just
play go I was gonna say play bowling
because that worked people don't go
bowling anymore
um or they do they go to group of
friends so the way people interact or
they quote unquote meet each other
that's the way people come into contact
with each other so I'm fine that I've
got my one of my oldest friends in the
world uh got married that way I got
family members who got um connected that
way that's fine I think with the mistake
we make is that we try to do all of the
quote-unquote getting to know you
electronically and remember this
electronic communication allows us to
transmit info
it does not allow us to get to know one
another or to connect with one another
full stop with a period at the end of
that sentence no I've got great friends
that I no no you have great people that
you communicate with that you give info
to
[Music]
but they're not your friends all right
next question what are your thoughts on
vaccines for kids
the best answer I can give you well geez
that got complicated real fast
um I give my kids the the
what is it the MMR my kids have that and
I keep them up to date on that I did not
choose to get my kids vaccinated with
code vaccine for a number of reasons the
data told me that um and I'm vaccinated
my wife's vaccinated but when it came to
kids the downstream response was so
um the data didn't back it up I'll just
stop there so and I by the way I
partnered with my doctor on that choice
it wasn't something I got off the
YouTubes anyway
all right thanks for that so it was fun
having a show guys
I'll give you an easy one do you like
Pop-Tarts if there's a Pop-Tart and it's
got frosting on the top of it sometimes
I like to like take the wrapper off real
slow and just rub it on my face
and just hold it there
yeah I do like Pop-Tarts but only the
ones with this with the stuff on the top
of them uh if they're just pop tarts
with stuff inside of them nah I need
both
oh that was disturbing all right why do
people cheat
I uh man people cheat for a whole bunch
of reasons I think the most convicting
explanation of cheating that I've heard
is from Esther perel which is this most
people who cheat
have not found something wrong with
their partner
they don't like who they have become in
the relationship
they have become boring they've become
isolated they become alone they've
become less sensual they've become
frustrating they become angry they've
become whatever adjective you want to
describe but it's a description of
yourself not of your partner now there
are people who are abusive there are
people who are emotionally and
physically not present right which
automatically leads to an arc
of behavior right so somebody doesn't
show up and at home they're abusive
they're whatever I'm gonna go find
connection with somebody else right and
I get that that's plausible but often
it's the not showing up it's the this
person is not safe and I become somebody
that I don't want to become all right
next question this is the worst by the
way this is like torture for me
to have one a lot of fun for us though
ah so great my wife would kill for this
just this a button that shuts me up
after a minute
uh what's the difference between
counseling and therapy
the difference between counseling and
therapy so counseling is
um it's become like a colloquial term
for advice giving
and it's not but you have like addiction
counselors and you've got Camp
counselors and you've got pastoral
counselors and you've got professional
counselors so when I use the word
counseling I use it in the
um professionalized sense not as an
advice giver but as a therapist and so
in its true a sense a therapist and a
counselor are the same therapy and
counseling are the same
when it's used interchangeably with
other things I was talking to somebody
the other day and they're like yeah I
was counseling a couple and I was
thinking you're not a therapist you're
not a licensed counselor so you were
just sitting down and talking with
somebody and you're giving them advice
that's totally different so in that case
know this
therapy is not advice
therapy is walking alongside somebody as
you all co-discover what's the next
right step for somebody it's not just
lecturing somebody all right uh this one
is similar to that one how do you break
up with a counselor or therapist
a therapist or counselor is a
professional relationship they're not
your friends so there is no breakup the
same as you would call a different
plumber the same as you would
um I don't know get a different yard
person you are going to choose to enter
into a new relationship now here's where
that's a little bit messy number one
counseling is intimate therapy is
intimate you discuss things with others
somebody that you don't just talk with
everybody about and so you feel attached
to that relationship
so understand it's going to be awkward
for you and treat it as a professional
relationship the second thing and this
is really important is some sort of
grenade throwing like they weren't good
for you so I'm gonna tell that that
never is helpful it's not cathartic it's
not going to make you feel any better so
you don't need to do that the third
thing is if they violate ethical
boundaries if they violate
confidentiality they lie to you about
price they don't talk to you about
confidentiality they ask hey can um you
do something for me by the way these
unethical things then you file that case
with the local
um uh ethics board right with the ethics
board there you go all right last one
what is the difference between counter
cancel culture and accountability
accountability is done number one in
relationship that's a great question
accountability is done in relationship
I've given you permission to speak into
my life or we've all live in the same
Society so we have a responsibility to
serve one another with accountability
but accountability always serves to help
both the situation at large Society
um this school building this group of
parents your kids and accountability
helps you it's me giving you wisdom and
insight and holding you to a set
standard that we've all agreed upon
cancel culture is I'm gonna kill you I'm
going to end your ability to earn a
living I am going to your ideas and your
words are so bad that I am going to end
your ability to use them
one of those is for building everybody
up
including somebody that has to have be
held accountable they have to be there
has to be a punishment right
um cancel culture is the act of
Destruction
that was it I hated that
we'll be doing it again of course we
will because I can see all high-fiving
each other back there you're like yes we
got him
so America if you like me stumbling
through my hands oh geez
that was hard
yeah those weren't easy questions if you
liked the lightning round let us know go
down in the comments below or send Kelly
an email her cell number is I'm just
kidding I won't do that uh go to John
delaney.com ask and put it in there and
if you have lightning round questions
like hey what's this this or this or
this let us know we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show
I love this song good job everybody in
the booth Ryan holiday's favorite band
ever Iron Maiden
in their famous song Lightning Strikes
twice I see what you did there
sounds like we're gonna have more than
one lightning round oh great here's the
song the lyrics go like this I feel the
breeze on my face and expectance not
very long before the storm reaches here
off in the distance the lightning is
flashing again feel something strong as
the power draws near is it the rolling
of Thunder that scares you is it the
Clashing of clouds it holds fear I love
Iron Maiden lyrics so great but all I
know is they sit in a corner alone and
it takes me back to my childhood again
all the people hurry inside is the
lightning flashlights dark the storm is
nearly here only God will know oh do
yourself a favor and listen to some Iron
Maiden today we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode holy cow
I'm talking to John deloney
the same thing holy cow I'm talking to
Grace this is amazing so I have an
eight-year-old daughter but she's still
I don't know how much of it is due to
abuse that she's witnessed at home her
dad had undiagnosed bipolar mental
health Diagnostics are a context not an
excuse you need some help with my
marriage you have come to the right guy
what's up next thing I know she sent me
a text in in January saying I'm ending
this marriage I'm moving out of the
house because this isn't help with your
marriage this is
this is you coming to terms with your
wife has left you
[Music]